L'ordinateur est un moyen incroyablement puissant
d'expression créative
mais pour la majeure partie
cette expression se limite aux écrans
de nos ordinateurs et téléphones portables.
Et j'aimerais vous raconter une histoire sur
comment amener ce pouvoir hors de l'ordinateur
pour faire bouger des choses et interagir avec nous
hors de l'écran et dans le monde physique
dans lequel on vit.
Il y a quelques années, j'ai eu un appel
d'un magasin de luxe appelé Barneys New York
et tout d'un coup voilà que
j'étais en train de concevoir des sculptures cinétiques
pour les vitrines de leurs devantures.
Celui-ci s'appelle « La Poursuite ».
Il y a deux paires de chaussures,
celle d'un homme et celle d'une femme,
et elles jouent cette poursuite lente et tendue
dans toute la vitrine
dans laquelle l'homme arrive derrière la femme
et se met dans son espace personnel,
et ensuite elle s'éloigne.
Chacune des chaussures a des aimants à l'intérieur,
et il y a des aimants en-dessous de la table
qui font bouger les chaussures.
Mon ami Andy Cavatorta construisait
une harpe robotique pour la tournée Biophilia de Bjork
et j'ai fini par construire l'électronique
et le logiciel de contrôle du mouvement
pour faire bouger et jouer la harpe.
La harpe a quatre balanciers séparés,
et chaque balancier a 11 cordes,
donc la harpe se balance selon son axe et fait une rotation
pour jouer plusieurs notes de musique
et les harpes sont toutes en réseau
pour qu'elles puissent jouer les bonnes notes
au bon moment de la musique.
J'ai bâti une exposition de chimie
au Musée des Sciences et de l'Industrie à Chicago,
et cette exposition permet aux personnes d'utiliser des objets physiques
pour attraper des éléments chimiques hors de la table périodique
et les amener ensemble pour causer
des réactions chimiques.
Le musée a remarqué que les personnes
passaient beaucoup de temps à cette exposition
et un chercheur d'un centre d'éducation scientifique
en Australie a décidé d'étudier cette exposition
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui était en train de se passer.
Elle a trouvé que les objets physiques
que les personnes utilisaient aidaient
pour comprendre comment utiliser l'exposition,
et aidaient les personnes à apprendre d'une manière sociale.
En y réfléchissant, cela a beaucoup de sens,
qu'utiliser des objets physiques spécialisés
aide les personnes à utiliser plus facilement une interface.
Je veux dire que nos mains et nos esprits sont optimisés
pour réfléchir et interagir avec des objets tangibles.
Pensez à ce que vous considérez le plus facile à utiliser
un clavier physique ou sur un écran
comme sur un portable ?
Mais ce qui m'a frappé
à propos de tous ces différents projets
est qu'ils sont vraiment construits en partant de zéro,
au niveau de l'électronique
et les circuits imprimés et
tous les mécanismes jusqu'au logiciel.
Je voulais créer quelque chose
où l'on pouvait bouger des objets sous contrôle de l'ordinateur
et créer des interactions autour de cette idée
sans avoir à parcourir ce processus
de construire quelque chose en partant de zéro
à chaque fois.
Donc ma première tentative
était au Media Lab du MIT
avec le professeur Hiroshi Ishii,
et on a construit cet ensemble de
512 électro-aimants différents,
et ensemble ils pouvaient faire bouger les objets
à leur surface.
Mais le problème avec cela
était que ces aimants
coûtent plus de 10 000 dollars.
Même si chacun était plutôt petit,
ensemble ils pesaient tellement
que la table sur laquelle ils étaient
a commencé à s'affaisser.
Donc je voulais construire quelque chose
où l'on pouvait avoir cette sorte d'interaction
sur n'importe quelle table.
Alors pour explorer cette idée,
j'ai construit une armée de petits robots,
et chacun de ces robots avait ce que l'on appelle des roues omni.
Ce sont ces roues spéciales
qui peuvent bouger aussi facilement dans toutes les directions,
et quand vous couplez ces robots
avec un projecteur vidéo,
vous avez ces outils physiques
pour interagir avec de l'information digitale.
Donc voilà un exemple de ce que je veux dire.
Ceci est une application d'édition de vidéos
où tous les contrôles
pour manipuler la vidéo sont physiques.
Donc si l'on veut peaufiner la couleur,
on entre juste le mode de couleur,
et ensuite on a trois boutons différents
pour peaufiner la couleur,
ou si l'on veut ajuster le son,
alors on a deux boutons différents pour ça, ces objets physiques.
Donc ici les canaux de gauche et droite restent synchronisés
mais si l'on veut, on peut passer outre cela
en saisissant les deux en même temps.
Donc l'idée est que l'on obtient les avantages de vitesse
et d'efficacité par l'utilisation de ces boutons physiques
ensemble avec la flexibilité et la versatilité
d'un système qui est conçu en logiciel.
Et ceci est une application de cartographie
pour la réponse aux catastrophes.
Donc il y a ces objets physiques
qui représentent la police, les pompiers et secours,
et le répartiteur peut les saisir
et les placer sur une carte
pour dire à ces unités où aller,
et ensuite la position des unités sur la carte
est synchronisée avec leur position
dans le vrai monde.
C'est une application de vidéo chat.
C'est fou combien d'émotions on peut transmettre
avec juste quelques simples mouvements
d'un objet physique.
Avec cette interface, on ouvre un immense champ de possibilités
entre les jeux de société traditionnels
et les jeux d'arcade,
où les possibilités physiques de l'interaction
rendent possibles pleins de différents styles de jeu.
Mais un des domaines par lequel je suis le plus excité
concernant l'utilisation de cette plate-forme
est de l'appliquer aux problèmes qui sont difficiles
à résoudre pour les ordinateurs ou personnes seules.
Un exemple de cela est le pliage de protéine.
Donc ici on a une interface
où l'on a des poignées physiques sur une protéine
et on peut prendre ces poignées
et essayer de bouger la protéine, essayer de la plier de différentes manières.
Et si on la bouge d'une façon qui n'a pas de sens
avec la simulation moléculaire sous-jacente,
on a cette réaction physique où l'on peut
vraiment sentir ces poignées physiques
qui tirent contre nous.
Donc sentir ce qui est en train de se passer
dans une simulation moléculaire
est un tout autre niveau d'interaction.
Donc on est juste en train de commencer à explorer
ce qui possible quand on utilise des logiciels
pour contrôler le mouvement
des objets dans notre environnement.
Peut-être qu'il s'agit de l'ordinateur du futur.
Il n'y a pas d'écran tactile.
Il n'y a pas du tout de technologie visible.
Mais quand on veut faire un chat vidéo
ou jouer
ou regarder nos diapos pour notre prochain TED Talk,
les objets sur la table prennent vie.
Merci
(Applaudissements)